you're getting the subway juice on you
that's there in New York yeah I know
we're heading down to Williamsburg lunch
taking the subway down there on the way
now we're gonna get an acquittal
[Music]
truth or dare first you first at bat
this year
Kenny smacks your face a slider first
pitch yes
what's going through your head at that
point well I just wanted to get the
first hit out of the way it was kind of
just oh wow
I'm here took a big rip but that that
first swing it's like a Max Scherzer did
what Max Scherzer does by making it not
be there thankfully I got first one out
of the way my last at-bat looped into
centerfield that's gonna fall for a base
at peeve Alonso with his first
big-league hit will go to another truth
with the scouting report on Tebow the
baseball player I'm not gonna give it
away because he said former teammate I
don't want to give away this thing but
I'll give you a fun fact he does not
believe in the baseball gods how does
that play out for them versus most
people who do believe guys that have
been in the game for a while it's like
they do they know the baseball gods
everything our shortstop made this
unbelievable diving catch I said
something like Oh baseball gods or
something about it's like they're gonna
do it right and you said what the hell
are you talking about or what the heaven
are you talking about because it's him
talking next pitch he blacks a double
off the wall and I just kind of looked
at him smile I need to toss people
arrested you got the football guys nope
nope oh gods all right Keith truth or
dare on this stuff do dare I've heard
you have a pretty good New York accent
so the chair is I want you to approach
someone on the subway and ask for
directions to Citi field's with this
great New York action that I've heard
that I gotta get all right
I excuse me sir can you do me a huge
favor can you give me directions to citi
field because I don't know if I'm in the
right direction I don't care if you're a
fan or not
I just need directions to Citi Field
just please out of the kindness of your
heart money money money money
what do you wanna do truth or dare I
just did it there so I'll just do it
I'll do a truth to mix it up can you out
lift everybody on the map probably not I
mean no one gets after it I mean Buffalo
is a really large human being I mean I
can move some weight around for sure but
if anyone probably Buffalo yeah I'll put
this in there no Abreu's it's like a
peach got a little bit of time we've got
another chance for truth or dare what do
you want to do I'll do it there you know
you're kind of a new star in New York
the Dare will be complete when you give
them your autograph and when you get
them to sign this Mets hat in exchange I
do on my autograph first baseman for the
Mets here pull up a picture on your
phone you should know know you're
supposed to sign this for me
what if I shine your jacket right there
beautiful you sign this for me
it's a sweet sing let's go match let's
go let's go Mets
truth or dare food truth what do you
think about the nickname fuller I love
it I mean Todd was just kind of messing
around and he's just like it just looked
like a Big Damn polar bear and I'm just
like all right we made it to Brooklyn we
have one more dare for you
okay we're done here we want you to give
a polar bear hug for the next person who
comes through the turnstile
might get punched in the face
I dare you to screaming Yankees suck
Yankees